as we've already talked about there are
a number of different people being sued
by dominion voting systems for the
allegedly
libelous claims that have been made by
people like rudy giuliani and trump's
other lawyer sydney powell although it
went back and forth as to whether she
really is his lawyer or not
and now she is coming up with what i
call the tucker carlson alex jones fox
news defense which is
you can't sue me over the things i said
about you dominion
because nobody in their right mind would
believe that i was saying things that
are actually to be believed this is
actually the defense that she's putting
out there
a forbes has a very interesting report
which explains that former trump lawyer
and conspiracy theorist sidney powell
moved to dismiss a lawsuit filed against
her by dominion voting systems
arguing that her earlier claims that
dominion was involved in an orchestrated
voter fraud effort
were so outrageous that quote reasonable
people would not accept such statements
as fact
we experienced this with tucker carlson
when
tucker was recently sued fox news
lawyers actually argued in court
people should understand viewers should
know that tucker
isn't reporting facts he's using
hyperbole and doing like an
entertainment show so you can't hold
them accountable for the things that he
says
which is a fascinating uh uh and of
course
true defense but not at all how fox news
wants to be understood they want to be
understood as reporting facts when it's
when it's convenient when the legal
rubber hits the road
all of a sudden these shows are
entertainment this is hyperbole this is
a performance
alex jones his lawyers using the defense
in one of the many lawsuits that alex
jones the conspiracy theorist faced
saying jones is playing a character on
his show
the things he are saying are more like
an actor reading lines
you wouldn't uh charge an actor with
sexual assault
because in character they admit to a
sexual assault
it's the same essential that they didn't
use that example but that's essentially
what they're saying
it's the same with alex jones and sidney
powell's lawyers yes
lawyers need lawyers that if maga stands
for anything it's making attorneys get
attorneys sydney powell's lawyers argued
that her claims about dominion
were quote opinions and legal theories
and not
statements meant for the public to
literally believe
and um that uh that she simply shouldn't
be held legally liable
in this way now what's completely
pathetic and transparent about this is
that she was saying these things
as a lawyer who was actually filing
motions now as we know
the trump campaign and administration
went back and forth
about whether sydney powell actually
represented them
trump did tweet multiple times listing
sidney powell as someone who was leading
the effort to overturn the election that
trump claimed was stolen from him after
she went cuckoo for coco puffs during
some press briefing
um meant to explain their legal strategy
the trump campaign or the trump white
house said she has nothing to do with us
but then she was back at the white house
meeting with trump and talking about
i don't remember if she was talking
about martial law or seizing voting
machines or whatever the case was
but the bottom line is that lawyers are
saying that this was just
these were just you know ideas they
weren't meant to be taken as fact
and uh she doesn't even really have
enough connection to this
area of law um and she shouldn't be held
accountable so
the the lessons here are number one
they are admitting she's a charlatan the
legal defense is based on
nobody should have believed the things
that she was saying and number two
this applies to so much of right wing
media
you know when when they get uh in
trouble for making completely dangerous
anti-medical anti-science-based
statements about coronavirus
um and the rubber meets the road legally
so to speak they say oh yeah i mean we
weren't giving medical advice this was
just like
these were just ideas and nobody should
take them seriously everybody should be
talking to
their doctor or whatever the case may be
and in fact there are
some right wing channels we were
watching a live stream of
i think it was on on right side
broadcasting
when um during cpac i think it was mike
lindell or someone else started making
bogus claims
about coronavirus and the election
results
they cut away and read a statement which
was about you know everybody should we
are not endorsing any of these claims
everybody should check with their own
doctors or whatever the case may be
so they all sort of know that this is
just
uh something they're doing for ratings
and to to create clicks and
interests but they will immediately
abandon these positions
as soon as it gets legally hot as it is
getting now for sydney powell and we'll
just follow and see ultimately what
happens
with this lawsuit against her but she's
going for the
no one could possibly have believed the
things i was saying anyway
defense one of our sponsors is vincero
watches giving you 15 off a high quality
wristwatch
is the perfect way to elevate your style
own at least one watch that makes you
feel great when you put it on
you can often see me wearing my vincero
watch on the show
mine is the gunmetal vessel model i'm a
big fan of the metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one year
return policy
and five year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman